there are actually six things that most
people have no idea about vitamins I'm
going to share with you today number one
most Mega vitamin companies are owned by
either big Pharma chemical companies or
food manufacturing companies okay these
companies own the big Brands uh bear for
example owns one a day and bear just
bought up a Monsanto right Pfizer owns
Centrum and emergency which by the way I
used to take this a long time ago Clorox
owns ReNew Life and then we have Nestle
the chocolate company that owns Garden
of Life Puritan's Pride pure Douglas
Laboratories wovenzyme solgar Nature's
Bounty and quite a few others you know
sometimes I I'm criticized for having my
own line of vitamins and I always ask
the person would you rather buy your
vitamins from a drug company a chemical
company or a food manufacturing company
or maybe a marketer chances are they're
not probably focused on getting
ingredients from soil that is really
really nutrient dense I mean one of our
products the wheatgrass juice powder I
flew out to the farm where they grow
this incredible product on a Thousand
Acre organic farm on an ancient sea bed
where the soil is so rich in trace
minerals versus using a chemical based
vitamin versus a food-based vitamin and
so even though some of these companies
have these very pure and standardized
ingredients and great manufacturing
practices the key is where do you get
these ingredients and is it possible to
know what individual is behind these
huge Brands to listen to their viewpoint
on these really key topics all right
number two 95 of all vitamin salt are
made
synthetically okay from chemical
companies that means they're made from
petroleum they're made from chemicals
coal tar they do not come from things
that are growing at all and maybe you're
told that there's no difference between
synthetic and natural vitamins they're
the same molecule well there's a huge
difference between that so-called
vitamin C ascorbic acid that you're
buying versus vitamin C in nature with
all the different complexities it's a
huge difference but when we're talking
about synthetics we're talking about
like ascorbic acid vitamin C B1 we're
talking about vitamin E
beta-carotene which is a precursor to
vitamin A that could be made
synthetically all right number three
China is the largest exporter of vitamin
C and B1 in the world okay the problem
with that is they're not too transparent
they don't really tell you their
manufacturing processes and the
regulations are just a bit Shady all
right number four the vitamin studies
that you actually read about online and
you hear in the news that show that they
increase the risk of cancer and heart
disease
only use synthetic they do not use
food-based complexes they don't use
natural vitamins okay so that's just a
little Omission a little thing that they
don't really tell you so then in your
mind in the medical professions mind
vitamins don't really create any
difference well again what kind of
vitamins are you talking about you're
talking about synthetic vitamins well
like I said before there's a huge
difference now I'm not against synthetic
vitamins used in short-term type things
for maybe detoxes but other than that
you shouldn't be taking a long term for
your maintenance or your health number
five whole food concentrates okay so
you're taking this maybe like a beet
leaf extract or some other plant and
you're concentrating it it could also be
a glandular tissue okay and that's
called a whole food concentrate and then
if you look at the amounts of vitamins
or nutrients in a whole food concentrate
they're much lower than synthetics
however
they're more complete because you have
all the cofactors you have the all the
enzymes you have all the trace minerals
you don't just have this synthetic
isolated fraction of a vitamin you have
the whole thing it's definitely more
bioavailable and it's definitely more
effective
even though it's in smaller amounts if
you look at some of these uh
multivitamin mineral products and you
look at the amounts they have like 17
000 percent of the rdas etc etc
you know they're using synthetic and
also if you look at the ingredients the
first one is usually calcium carbonate
so anytime you see the first ingredient
in calcium carbonate the majority of
that product is the calcium carbonate
that's why it's so heavy it's like a
paperweight calcium carbonate is
limestone and you'd be better off
chewing on the cement right outside your
house because it's really you're eating
rocks it's very very cheap it's very
difficult to absorb you have to kind of
go through like 12 different steps
before it gets absorbed in your body all
right and number six
um medical doctors don't get a lot of
training in vitamins they really only
get about 25 hours on average of
training in nutrition 25 hours is that
really enough
to have a grasp on all the vitamins to
be able to give advice to have an
opinion on it 25 hours you're going to
be an expert in well they're not experts
in it they're experts in drugs and
surgery and other things but the point
is that this right here is just not
enough training to
be able to give a good opinion one way
or the other now I think it's important
to understand what foods are the most
nutrient dense for that video check this
out right here